there was certainly a lot to criticize
it was a failure of government at every
level the scale of Hurricane Katrina
overwhelmed the Federal Emergency
Management Agency FEMA they were not
prepared for a crisis of that size and a
dislocation of that many people
emergency response in the United States
is typically driven by states and
localities first with federal assistance
coming in behind that and you also had
multiple levels of breakdown in the city
of New Orleans in the state of Louisiana
as well and so the agencies were
uncoordinated FEMA had recently become
part of the newly created Department of
Homeland Security and so the chain of
command issues also came into play there
as well and so instructions would be
given from Washington that would change
on the ground and then coordinating with
local and state officials became almost
impossible because of the corruption and
troubles that they had within their own
governments and pardon the expression
but it was a perfect storm of government
failure at all level yeah but as you
make clear their problems in terms of
where the orders are coming from who's
taking the orders the logistics the
processes but it also was seen at our
correspondents referred to President W
Bush he was flying over in Air Force one
not landing and it was peculiar wasn't
it because we thought back to 9/11 we
see george w bush with a bullhorn
addressing the firefighters this was a
man who who got the crises when it comes
to the public relations and he lost the
touch when it came to Katrina what
happened I think it was a again a
breakdown at all levels and in that
particular case the the pilots were
instructed not to come in it would have
been more of a complication to bring the
airplane in then to land I think in
retrospect it would have been better
just to figure out how to get that plane
on the ground there so he could have
been the commander-in-chief the the
trusted base of the government on the
ground so I think everyone regrets not
having done that whether or not it would
have helped is another matter I think
that like I guess the like I said
earlier the scale of the devastation was
so strong that every pre-planned
intervention and response was inadequate
to the scale of the storm you know over
the years about 71 billion dollars of
flown in to New Orleans
from the federal government and even
though as your correspondent reported
the recovery has been uneven there is
something of a miraculous rebirth that's
happened in your son to that but I sort
of finish